here comes the boss how you doing good
to see you it's going great big night
for you tonight now Reese the first
thing
like you make such great choices about
what you want to produce but what's the
first thing that you look for or that's
is it something that just speaks to you
when it's a project that you a book
you've read or whatnot well this one was
the book Taylor chicken wrote the most
amazing novel and it was it read like a
movie or a television show like just
episodic and and it felt like at this
time period that people are obsessed
with but we haven't seen something in
this time period so long NHS was so it
was ready to be the best television show
ever also the original music
you know the excitement I I had a little
bit of an experience not a little bit it
was like a huge experience in my life
doing Walk the Line the Johnny Cash
story and the time that we spent
rehearsing and learning the songs
together made us really connected and I
remember visiting them in the studio and
I was like you guys are gonna remember
this forever as an actor as a band
member as a fellow performer they just
supported each other and were there for
each other and you could tell they have
insane chemistry
yeah
can make a good thing
what did you think when you first heard
them as a band were you like whoa well I
went to this uh session where they
played the songs and I nearly fell out
of my chair it was just so beautiful
that they had taken the time to learn
these instruments to really learn to be
in sync with each other and I mean the
original songs
I can't you're gonna die they want to go
on tour you know they the man wants to
go on too you need to go on tour and
especially there's like
there's like two or three songs that you
will never be able to shake they're so
good oh we can make a good thing but
yeah
[Music]
um so my friend had read the book I had
not read the book I saw the series they
were peppering me like what about this
what about this I didn't want to say
anything so what how do you decide what
you're gonna keep in what you're gonna
take out oh that's up to Scott
newstatter and Will Graham the writer
they just did an incredible job
um kind of condensing it but also like
taking different threads and making them
more substantial so there's definitely
story lines that are bigger than in the
book but it's really it's just a delight
from start to finish what's the chances
we can get more Daisy Jones because I
got questions comments
I mean I think you know let's see how
many people watch it and download the
songs but I I mean I'm here for it Daisy
Jones again Daisy Jones of the seven
and the Seven are you joining Maybe
I don't know what I do I play the
tambourine
you always need a good tambourine player
okay finally we just finished Morning
Show
three words to describe this season uh
just drama
Romance
um
just all the feels okay drama romance
and the feels I can dig it all right
thank you
[Music]